alright alright guys I'm making this
because Benny
damnit Benny don't be a [ __ ] robbed
I've been he's getting me to watch his
let's play on silent hill's and silent
it's scary man this game is scary so I'm
only gonna watch a little bit of it like
I watched I got about five minutes in
earlier and I was like man [ __ ] that
because it was it was scary
so alright let's do this thing with the
wife I'm starting with the wife ending
with that I've been the same hallway
oh my god alright 23:59 I don't do good
with these games who rips pictures
picture jail for ripping the pictures
anyway guys what I was saying before is
this let's play channel is getting a
reboot and I'm gonna be playing very of
fudge ton of games just I am we've been
putting it up this channel and of course
we'll be still doing the eligible
monster main channel I'll still be doing
the comic story and channel I just like
making videos and playing games and I
hope you guys enjoy why is the door shut
now it's the same hallway hello there
creaking like the background sounds okay
zoom in oh God
I wouldn't be able to use the you can
stay in there it's okay I hate bugs but
those things are huge well I'll make it
through this in the box
deeper and deeper into my own house
where I've repeatedly built the same
hallway this is this is gonna be so good
like is it ever gonna turn midnight and
oh good the doors open we're just gonna
go downstairs hit the next floor it'll
be fine because I'm pretty sure that
this isn't what yeah
the ruby was stuck in one room this time
stuck in a hallway I understand how
you're so calm during this let's play
where I stopped the last time like the
door Oh God
the door closer than the bathroom door I
want to go to the bathroom thank you for
the offer but here but you don't see it
because you're facing the door to try to
get out of there
oh god it's a baby my worst nightmare
hmm we're going this way
this Way's not scary I'm gonna go hide
over here with his alive I know I'm
coming after me and I'm just gonna go
hide over do what I want
Karen sleep for three days like I had to
watch cartoons after I finished my I
don't have an Ice Age man I know like
when scary movies used to be on TV I was
like when they finished I was like oh
it's it's like 11 or 12 o'clock I should
go to bed but I can't because I'm all
wound up so I gotta watch this like kids
card chocolate I can chill out a little
bit it's a spider web there okay I was
born I was worried you were gonna turn
around though it's gonna be well part of
the video before you're leaving the
chocolate on the personal hell well I
just I get really scared during this leg
doing this kind of stuff like I watched
PewDiePie let's be able to grow instead
of just straight straight I'm not going
to ten minutes right now there's
something standing in the hallway
Oh her oh god the light went out
I don't watch this anymore exact same
segment Oh God
yeah give away [ __ ] move away
thinking I hear her breathing shut the
[ __ ] up Vinny shut up shop just don't
the door the door go down you look
around I would you why would you walk
towards it she's not here and she's not
crying anymore okay okay same room yep
this is totally normal I'm just in a
really long hallway in a house it just
goes down and down and our god oh god
there's a door opening again is that go
around the golf with dad for the love of
God Betty don't go Oh God give me that
give me that okay something is gonna
jump out I can do something it's gonna
jump out the door closed all right I see
dirty water someone doesn't know how to
drain the oh look it's a hole in the
wall that's freaking awesome what is
that oh my [ __ ] god what is that [ __ ]
in the sink oh bloody fetus on the
ground doesn't even look like a bird
fetus there's something wrong bird legs
and arms
no no no no no creepy lady go away
creepy lady go away cause you let me go
away if you let it go away keep your let
it go away
there's some pretty please are useless
they just screaming to the sinks all
bloody I can't wait for this game
there's the howl you must get bring it
home you're not crying anymore
you're really breathing you still look
like a dead chicken like I don't want
you to leave your so I'm just sitting
here staring at her door
they got the door sound effect this is
safe hello
like I would just dive through the wind
in our hands like you are back into the
hallway the hallway is the safe place at
the moment next repeat all go don't
skate this should been run why is the
light now as lights around
why is my flashlight garbage why is it
still twenty videos more often yeah not
do this more often than a ceiling I want
us to be electronic bass things
doors open garbage
you could you could play scary games and
then you could watch the video and react
to them why not good turn his webcam on
make his own video I don't like the
breathing I don't like everything I
don't like the breathing okay
like I know something's gonna scare the
[ __ ] out of me right now why is the door
shut if you put that up in your channel
people are gonna want you to play those
games
I am NOT playing that's why I don't play
scary games my scare game experience
stopped with Resident Evil 3 I don't
play did you that was my reaction to
during it you heard it yeah I heard you
that was like horrified honestly like I
I jumped in like yelped a couple times
well that is a genuinely scary game oh
my god no question I am not buying that
game